[Music]
what else is going on in your life i'm a
pretty simple man a little thing will
put me in a good mood for about a work
week five days oh yeah little things
will catch me just right i was traveling
from new york recently uh and on my way
through airport security i don't know
about you guys but when i fly i love
wearing a t-shirt that i don't care
about i actually know very little about
you guys
but when i fly i always wear a shirt
that i don't care about because when i
fly i get really sweaty i don't know why
do you sweat when you fly not really no
i'm drenched you get you you sweat a lot
i don't know what it is i'm just sitting
there i get off the plane i got pit
stains my brow is all glistening people
like you've been jogging i'm like no
i've been sitting still in the sky
so i was wearing a shirt that i don't
care about and this is what put me in a
good clean burning mood for five days i
was wearing the shirt that is soft but i
don't like to wear in public just want
to fly sometimes it says dr seuss green
eggs and ham that's the shirt it's an
old shirt you've had just an old shirt
you put it on dr seuss green eggs and
him it was a gift i got i was like they
clearly don't know how cool i am
then i got it a second time and it was
like god himself being like put on the
shirt yeah okay so i gave you that face
please wear the outfit as well
so
i don't know if that's hurtful and i
wore that shirt and i'm going through
airport security it's like 7 30 in the
morning i'm a little bit grumpy i go
through that machine that's killing us
all
bathing us in strange rays why do we
agree to that i don't know it's just
like it's fine some guy with a bond like
a wand and a radio is like it's fine i'm
like okay
i go in i'm grumpy i'm it's like 7 30 in
the morning get out i forget that i'm
wearing the shirt
i don't even see this tsa woman she's in
my periphery and i just hear her go
what you know about green eggs and hair
five days of a good mood because a woman
what you know about queen and i forgot
that i was wearing the shirt
i didn't know what you saw i was like is
that a security question
who are green eggs what is ham are these
sleeper cells i don't have anything on
me
conan i have that stuck in my head now
do it more time what you know it just
turns into tracy morgan over here yeah
what you know about green eggs i am liz
lemon
everybody's pregnant
how can you be sad when that exists no
that was a terrific thing for you that's
what i'm saying it's a tool for you you
can use it if you're ow if you're a
target which i'm sure you go to target
from time to time yeah and you're
waiting for a parking spot and then some
jerk one of these jerks you see out
there yeah
pulls in and he pulls in a giant
i'm against him
i'm anti-jerk too takes your parking
spot now you can give up and give in to
despair and the ugliness of the world
and just be like oh you son of a [ __ ]
yes
words
to the guy yeah that's a failure he's
already unhappy happy people don't steal
spots or you can confuse him
roll down the window and look right at
him i mean right at him like a college
freshman playing hey there delilah on
the acoustic just through him right
i know that look right yeah and when you
lock on just go
what you know about reactor
[Applause]
would you could you want to bump
your donuts donuts of joy in the car
yeah
that's a victory for freaking out for
team half you win every time in that
situation that's what i'm saying it's up
to us